it's great to welcome to the program
today Renato Mariotti who's a former
federal prosecutor CNN legal analyst and
political legal affairs columnist great
to have you on really appreciate it
happy to be on thank you so let's just
dive right into it my perspective on the
bar team's handling of the end of the
Moller investigation and the release of
the report has been that I think they've
executed it quite well they've executed
it well in terms of the release of this
four-page letter that preceded the
actual report by a couple of weeks most
Americans are not going to page through
a 450 page report understandably they
have jobs they've got to get their kids
to school I understand it and that
letter was a really great basis for what
I'm calling the exoneration tour so like
big picture what's your sense do you
agree that this was pretty good strategy
could they have done better yeah I have
to say it's master deception by bar I
think it's good for good for bar good
for Trump bad for America and I what I
would say is that you know what we were
promised with the United States Senate
was promised by bar was transparency
that he would you know lay out this
report and its findings for the American
people and he failed to do so he
deliberately failed to do so even when
Muller was urging him on multiple
occasions to release the summaries which
really contain everything I mean if if
somebody reads the summaries they
basically get the gist of what happened
in the report
you know bar deliberately hid the
summaries for weeks while he had this
very highly misleading letter that it
was out there and was setting the
narrative so yeah I agree with you I
think that he misled America misled
Congress and that's not what an attorney
general supposed to be doing but it
worked as a political matter it appears
to work very well as we've started to
learn a bit about some of the
conversations and the mindset of
Muller's prosecutors throughout the
process for example as one example we
recently learned from a report that a
couple of prosecutors a year a year and
a half ago sort of determined that they
will
that the president had committed
obstruction but that for what are
effectively political reasons the
difficulty if not impossibility
depending on who you ask
of indicted a sitting president that it
was sort of let go that's my terminology
not theirs when you saw that report does
that strike you generally speaking as
the type of conversation that
prosecutors would have or was there
something about the generalities of how
those prosecutors are reported to have
been thinking about this that doesn't
line up with how your experience is that
prosecutors behave and talk and think
about charges Wow well I mean here
you're talking about investigation of
the President of the United States and
so the Muller team always knew that the
way this was going to end was going to
be different than the way that most
investigations end okay when I was a
prosecutor I was thinking about what
would my indictment look like what
charges am I going to bring what do I
need to prove to carry those charges and
so the conversation was always about
what a trial would look like what the
evidence would look like at trial and
then for the Muller team who was always
going to be a different sort of question
a different sort of analysis question
was it would always be you know not
anything about a trial or whether or not
they would be able to prevail but
whether or not there would be sufficient
evidence to support some sort of
findings regarding the president or you
know or you know his associates or
things like that now if certainly I
think there were some charging decisions
that were made as to other individuals
to nourish strong brothers but as to the
president I think um the the
conversation was very unusual and
different than a typical conversation
would be and then the separate questions
separate issue is what do you do about
that and Muller came came up with one
answer Barr came up with another I mean
for Muller the question that the the
conclusion was because we can't indict
it would be unfair to Trump for us to
reach a conclusion that he couldn't go
to court in Rabat in a way that a
typical defendant could bar
I leaped into this and saying no I mean
in fact his testimony today before the
Senate is no it would be improper not to
reach a conclusion but then instead of
going to Muller and asking him to make
the conclusion he made the conclusion
himself which I think fits with what he
said earlier which is that the goal here
was to deceive or hide or control or
spin or whatever whatever word you want
to use to suggest that he's think we're
giving a picture to the American public
that's inconsistent with the so use sort
of alluding to something that is is
related to this in a way which is that a
lot of non lawyers have issued different
opinions about the importance of the use
of certain legalese in the bar letter
and in the Moller report the use of the
word established in some cases find in
others as one example can you give us a
sense of I mean is that is that a
reasonable analysis to be doing is that
actually going to give us any insight
into sort of what is being said versus
what is being implied or those analyses
not particularly useful are we talking
about I'm sorry are you asking about the
Mullen report of the bar letter really
both I mean let's start with the bar
letter right the use of did not
establish versus there is no evidence
and sort of all of these different
semantic arguments that were made by non
legal analysts here's what I would say
the bar letter is crafted in a way to I
would say mischaracterized the Muller
report bar was trying to find a way to
write a letter that was technically
accurate so that you could not point to
a word and say this is a lie this
sentence is a complete lie so that it's
technically accurate but it's highly
misleading so he quoted half of a
sentence here or a clause there from the
report he never quoted a full sentence
when the Muller report and then he used
words that were as you're suggesting saw
you know well it didn't establish this
you know didn't reach this conclusion
whatever so that those are not legal
terms deliberately because then this way
there could be a disagreement as to what
a stab
amen and so I'd say that the bar letter
was a masterwork of deception that's
that's that would be the conclusion and
I draw I would say that the Muller
report is something very different
the Muller report is very careful and
guarded and um humble I mean I tend that
molars approach is very humble which is
how we expect a prosecutor to be in
other words if you had a picture of the
ideal prosecutor it would be someone
who's humble who has a sense of fair
play who doesn't go beyond what is
strictly known what prosecutors are
supposed to be that way and
unfortunately they often fall short of
that in real life but Robert Moeller I
think was trying to do whatever he could
to reach that ideal what do you make of
the motivation to include some of the
particular foot notes that are in the
molar report just to pick one there's
this footnote in volume 2 I think it's
either like 1090 or 10 10 91 which which
in short and correct me if my
interpretation is wrong as a non legal
interpretation it says that whether or
not there is impeachment that barring
some kind of statute of limitations that
that would preclude this that a
president can be indicted after they are
no longer President of the United States
what do you think was the significance
or motivation for putting something like
that in a footnote I think the
motivation was to explain why detailed
findings are being set forth on issues
that aren't going to result in charges
so typically let's say I'm investigating
a bank robbery okay it's a typical
federal crime well you investigate and
then there's an indictment that's the
document yeah not a report prosecutors
usually don't write reports they write
indict or they don't or they write a
memo that says we decline the case an
internal memo publicly either there's an
indictment if there's not so what Moe is
trying to do is explain when there's
going to be no charges why go through
all this effort to set forth all the
details and go through all the facts and
lock it all in and I think the the
reasoning that Muller and his team had
is that well years later somebody may
try to prosecute this and we want to
have everything set forth in a way that
uh you know you know makes that possible
you know essentially I serves the
purposes of that potential prosecution
earlier in the program today we talked
about what we learned yesterday that
there was both a letter and a phone
conversation between Robert Moeller and
William Barr we're in short Robert
Miller felt that the if not the letter
specifically the sort of context and
reaction to the letter mischaracterized
the sort of sort of general picture of
what the molar report found how
significant is this I mean there's the
relatively few other examples that we
can look at to compare what's happening
here - what has happened historically
there are a couple
so can you gotta give us a sense of
whether this is this a big deal is it
not a big deal I was just a very big
deal Muller I mean the the picture of
Muller that is painted by his report is
an extraordinarily careful man
you know I don't think anybody any
lawyer sophisticated lawyer reading that
report can come away with anything other
than enormous respect for the man in his
work I mean I think it's it's something
that demands it's a it's a work product
that demands respect and he's careful
and cautious as I mentioned a moment ago
and here he is in the days after the bar
letter is released very pointedly I'd
say in a letter pointedly at least for
Robert Muller making the case that you
know he he claims that that there is a
mischaracterization of the substance of
his of his findings is the conclusions
of his investigation I think that for
Robert Muller that's as close as you're
going to ever get to something that is a
three alarm fire in making a very
pointed statement very careful man so
yeah I think it's very significant I
think the significance of it can be lost
potentially to the public because unlike
some of the pithy statements that Barr
says that are made for television Barr
excuse me Muller is trying to do exactly
the opposite Muller is trying to say
things in a careful and garden way and
even there he's I think making some
pretty strong statements and really what
I would just say here is you know Muller
pink is his deal you know dealing with
bar is if he's someone who has respect
for the institution and cares about
doing the right thing I mean we're
ballers telling him is the public's
being misled you need to correct this
you need to do something about and I
think what he didn't learn until it was
too late is that bar has no shame
whatsoever that even in the face of the
public being misled bar was going to do
nothing for weeks because that's exactly
what bar was firm last thing I want to
touch on and this is really more of a
political assessment than a legal one
unbalanced based on everything that's
happened until now does impeachment of
the president make sense aside from
whether it's politically viable and
whether any Republicans in the Senate
would actually say yes what what's your
sense of whether there should be such
proceedings well that's a great question
I'm not a politician okay so I don't I'm
not going to make a judgement as to
what's gonna happen in the Senate or how
all that's gonna work out I can tell you
as a lawyer that there's you know more
than sufficient evidence to charge
Donald Trump with obstructing justice
and if he had resigned as president last
you know before Muller concluded his
investigation I don't think there's a
doubt in my mind that Muller would have
been dining if he was no longer the
sitting president so Congress can decide
to do what it will with that I you know
they there's all sorts of statements
being made by Nancy Pelosi that it's not
in their political interest to impeach
sort of beyond my expertise I'm not
going to tell Nancy Pelosi how to run or
her political operation but I will say
there is you know more than sufficient
evidence to do so and frankly there's
there's much more evidence than there
wise I think of evidence I would say a
much more serious violation than than
the than the charges that ultimately
resulted in the impeachment of workman
we've been speaking with Varnado
Mariotti former federal prosecutors CNN
legal analyst and also Politico legal
affairs columnist really appreciate your
time today thank you very much